let's talk about let's talk about what
if Trump loses but insists c1 how many
times have they written articles like
this where it's like all the time
it's it's been you know there was a
there's a funny tweet I saw and it said
if you're one of these people that's
retweeting the story that says Trump is
not going to leave the White House
you're the rube like you're like you're
the target of their of their grift you
know they're gonna keep writing these
stories cuz they know you're gonna keep
clicking on them and they write new
versions every single time G you know
what you know what like Trump said if he
loses what they're like what do you do
if you lose and he's like then I lose I
don't like it's a very like boring
answer like I go I leave like joke
talking about Joe Biden apparently said
something like you have to get the
military to pull Trump out gosh why are
they engaging in this kind of rhetoric
you know I mean like shouldn't they just
keep their mouths shut
what was it what do you got spritz we
got spritz of cat-time and she's gone
okay okay but let's let's let's let's
stop worrying about the castle's let's
say other story check it out yeah well
actually the first no no I want to
actually comment on that
cuz it it makes me think every single
thing that's happening is is the
Democrats firing all the weapons they've
got that's why I bought in saying
something because they are in a corner
with every single blade out throwing him
in every direction like fire everything
mines like he's gonna cheat Trump like
no I'd leave we talk about well so walk
out of the White House like here's what
other options hmm yeah this scenario is
very similar to when we talked about
before okay where they're like you know
Trump doesn't win so they accuse you
know the Democrats of cheating or
claimed there was Chinese interference
and then jam up via let the process so
that nobody wins and then the Supreme
Court or the or the house side with
Trump well didn't the Supreme Court just
rule that the states have to give their
popular vote to the electoral you have
to give the electoral votes right wins
the who win to the state the state no no
in this oh oh in the state yeah so if a
state says Donald Trump won then the
electoral votes have to go to trump mmm
no faithless electors because people
tried voting for
the random people in 2016 right yes like
just like I don't agree with anyone
they're not supposed to do that and
interestingly I mean the electoral
college vote is a remnant of the olden
days you know that one of the one of the
features of the electoral college was
that you know you'd send electors to be
like here's what our state has chosen
right so in the state voted for
something the elector represents that
state so that still makes sense for a
lot of other reasons electro college is
all about proportional representation
right and then you know we negotiate the
power based on the population so you
have your Senators plus your Republic
plus your uh your congressmen so it's
it's the electoral college in my opinion
is a very very very important structure
okay because it makes sure that we don't
have mob you know majority rule
basically mob a majority rule what I
mean is if you had just the popular vote
then you'd have Chicago Los Angeles and
New York controlling everything right
now it's a democracy right and right and
it doesn't work it doesn't work so what
you end up getting is let's say they
find you know fresh water and I actually
know we will use the Great Lakes as an
example okay if Los Angeles was facing
if California is facing another drought
and then it was based on popular vote
California would lobby and be like why
don't we get the water from Chicago and
then New York would we know depending on
where it which which way they go it's
gonna be all about the big cities you
know so these way explains people's when
I went to California and there was an
area where the well water had run dry
because the farmers were digging deeper
and deeper and deeper there was a
drought going on so it's not solely the
issue of voting but one of the issues
was that they had they had a lot of
surface water in the farms okay but
because the big cities have more people
they voted the surface water goes to the
cities so now you had poor people living
in rural areas who had their water
surface water taken away from them by
the big cities hmm so you know that's
that's a really good example of the
problem if you live in the middle of
nowhere and you have a pond the big city
can just vote and come and take it away
they still can do that both with the
electoral college it makes it much more
difficult for big for the bigger
populations to oppress the smaller
states in the smaller populations water
wars that is coming it's coming too so
so anyway
they're their pitch here what I think is
interesting about this story is two
things
first they say that basically you know
Trump barely loses then bill Barr claims
there was cheating and then you know
like a fight fighting breaks out and the
house rules in favor of Trump but they
also mention here at the bottom that
what did they say
fart hold on let me see yeah they
talking about near Civil War in the
streets what they say the danger of an
undemocratic outcome only grows in other
scenarios that were war gamed by other
participants for instance what if there
is no clear-cut winner on election night
with Biden narrowly ahead in the
electoral college but with Michigan
North Carolina and flora still too close
to call the participants in that war
game concluded the result would be near
civil war in the streets far-fetched
rumors are enough to bring out armed
right-wing militias today imagine how
they would respond if they imagined that
there was an actual plot afoot to steal
the election from their hero Wow
you know I actually agree with it okay
because I've talked to some people I've
had people message me saying straight up
if they see you know that the elections
being stolen the militias will come out
yeah but they're saying that they're out
right now like I don't see I don't see
well they're talking about gettysburger
saying that the militias that showed up
in Gettysburg fell for the hoax that
antiva was gonna burn flags I haven't
seen anything from getting did was their
emotions that showed up at Gettysburg I
heard I heard it was happening
apparently so I seen articles I didn't I
have yet to see I am I'm sure people
have been talking to me about it
and I'm sure they would have sent me
images there there's people that follow
me that live in Gettysburg but told me
about that that was gonna happen
they I'm I'm I'm positive they would
have sent me something if they showed up
the only militia that I've seen marching
down the road is the the guys in Georgia
yeah well so like taunting the the
supposed right side militias like bring
it on let's fight it's like what yeah
hundreds of people showed up okay so you
do have some air yeah and Gettysburg so
links to it listen the point is I agree
that right-wing militia groups will come
out if they think the elections being
stolen yeah but what will they do like
that well they're trying to insinuate is
that
winged militias I mean think about what
they're saying near Civil War in the
streets right-wing glitches will come
out are they implying that's the
right-wing militias that'll be you know
milling about with guns shooting at
people and stuff like that because that
has not happened right what has happened
is the far-left anti-shah black lives
matter groups have shot many people it's
true have there have there been
right-wing militias who have engaged in
that stuff in the in recent and my fam I
am I forgetting something
I know there have been far-right
extremists yeah who have carried out
like lone wolf
you know terror attacks you know you'd
remember it because you know they would
be talking about it non-stop after yeah
it'd be everywhere there be there would
be no escaping that kind of conversation
yeah exactly
they'd be like that's proof that they
want that to happen they can't wait they
wouldn't love that there'd be like Oh
ice cream let's pry it out i I think
that I think it's correct that there
would be near civil war in the streets
and I and I've explained this to some of
my friends that I'm like listen man
you've you've never faced down the mob
the way I or many others have there's no
reason like there's no reasoning you
can't argue with them that's true so a
good example is when luke rudkowski of
we are change was in hamburg for the g20
yeah and he was walking with a local
journalist this guy max and someone
yelled nazi schweinhund you know and
then random people heard it i started
punching him and not in like pushing him
down and they chased him down for yeah a
while and then the police rescued him
Luc's like an Luke's Luke's are right
like I think is an anarchist you know a
right-wing like on an arbor capitalist
so that he actually I'm pretty sure he
hangs out with like right and left wing
and archetypes yeah he's not even he's
not even a wing he yeah he's like
another wing yeah yeah exactly
well he's an cat broke off of the wing
animal but he's always been like that
no thank you no he stands apart my
understanding is that the people he
hangs out with a lot of them are like I
don't want to say an taifa yeah but
close without the violence because true
anarchists don't believe in that but
like you know so he gets he gets pointed
out he gets physically attacked and so I
tell my friends I'm like when the chaos
starts no one knows if you're on their
side but if you're wearing very like
obvious militia type gear or you know a
right-wing looking thing or American
flag you know where you can stand to be
safe I've been in situations where the
mob is active
and you know one example is I think it
was I think it might've been like June
5th could be getting the date wrong in
2015 or 16 min I can't remember but it
was in San Jose you can google this and
there was a mob of people running around
outside of a trump rally beating people
one guy who was with the crowd got
beaten to know and he was like what why
did everybody start hitting me and I'm
like cuz it's a mob that you yeah
control him yeah
so I I've been talking to you know some
of my more lefty friends and I'm like
listen I'm telling you I know you when
this happens I know which side you'll be
on and you're not gonna be on the side
of the left wingers you're not you think
you might be but you won't be you might
be running around with them but the
moment it gets crazy
you'll be standing behind the right-wing
militias in in minutes yeah because like
watch some of these videos man these
people just are reckless and destroying
things they fight each other there's a
video out of Portland a couple days ago
that Andino tweeted about where he's
like in the absence of police they fight
themselves and it happens because some
people are like hey don't burn this
building down in those sides like a few
and then they start fighting I mean look
at New York right now look at Chicago
there's there's been so many death so
many shootings it's it's crazy it's
already a warzone you know and then and
then look at what happened in Atlanta
you know that that family was just
turning around they went past the
barricade turned around and the black
lives matter movement shot at him
because they were in their their zone
and killed the eight-year-old
eight-year-old girl is not safe you will
not be safe but I'll tell you what I've
been to events where there have been
right-wing militias like the oathkeepers
in the three-percent okay and they're
the most disciplined people there and to
be fair to I have been to events where
there have been like communist socialist
armed factions they are also the most
discipline on the ground yeah and I
think it's got something to do with the
respect for the firearm so like I've
actually seen like armed communist
people and they're very like we don't
want any violence man cuz you do not
want to go there but then you have these
young people who are just violent and
angry mm-hmm so you know typically in
there I think one of the funnier stories
is that when I was in Ferguson the
oathkeepers were there and a bunch of
these black lives matter activists were
yelling and I'm like what are you doing
and then they were like we're here to
make sure everyone stays safe and
they're like the only
problem we have the police and they're
like we know that's why we want to make
sure everyone stays safe and they're
like wait what and the oath keepers were
like we swore an oath to the
Constitution you know we don't like
police brutality we want to make sure
everybody stay safe and they're like oh
I think they don't like they see in the
media what these people are and yeah
they may be right-wing conservative
traditionalists yeah but they're like
anti violence they're like everybody
keep calm stay cool
yeah and they're gonna make sure you
know so peaceful approach when I when I
see I was actually at an event in Boston
and there were three percenters I don't
know a whole lot about what that
represents soon but they were stopping
the right from engaging with the left so
when the left was like trying to tagging
eyes it was the three percenters who are
like yelling at the right Bing let's not
back off back off yeah keeping the peace
and making sure none of them were armed
you know but they were they were like if
they weren't there it would have been I
think everybody would just clash start
fighting the cops were there too but
there were a few people who walked over
to their group and it was the three
percenters who pushed the right side
back saying don't engage with them and
it's all it also has to do in my opinion
with like optics you know as soon as the
right side throws one punch every camera
boom that's a front page of every
newspaper yeah exactly
yeah they don't care if it's the left
that's throwing punches so here's what
here's at CNN rights June 11th here's
the real danger if Donald Trump loses
the 20/20 election wait yeah the first
paragraph is the only thing I'm really
concerned about Joe Biden said Wednesday
night that he believes if President
Donald Trump loses the election and
refuses to leave the White House many of
the former generals who used to work for
him quote will escort him from the White
House with great dispatch cool something
Joe Biden believes great news and what a
great news and and sososo Biden's giving
you this like dude these people live in
an action movie yeah it's just not real
life it's very exciting mm-hmm it's a
movie yeah yeah so they're saying that
they've they've glorified movies and
we've we've turned our heroes into fake
characters and that's what real life is
to them the reality is based on movies
and books there's always a bad guy there
always has to be a bad guy right now
it's like well what they've presented
but Donald Trump was like on a silver
platter for them like Oh perfect we have
a bad guy he's gonna how old is he he's
about to be 80
like the iDEN no no Trump 74 74 oh man
I'm Way off Biden's about to be 80-78
anyway alright I got his age wrong yeah
point I was gonna I was gonna make is
even Trump is an old man he's not gonna
like rip his shirt off and then go like
jean-claude van damme fighting the
generals like what are the things gonna
happen no like he's gonna mobilize we're
like the army in front of the White
House and like fight a general no
there's a reason he didn't send people
into Seattle because he didn't that that
the optics that we were just talking
about that's terrible but also that's
what Democrats wanted him to do they
wanted to be a dictator but he's not
exactly so so so they keep acting like
Trump is a fascist and he's barely using
his power yeah so it's like they think
you know nobody November 4th like 3:00
in the morning the results have come in
Trump loses narrowly and there's gonna
be in the Oval Office and his loyalists
are gonna be like it's the generals
throw outside to remove you what do we
do and then he rips his shirt off and
he's got like dual host holsters you
know like we're not going anywhere
that's like what what are the things
gonna happen he's probably that probably
exactly that not joking
Jonas comes out of the roof I'm with you
right now mr. president he comes out
like of a cabinet like what Alex Jones
you've been there the whole time yes he
takes off the tinfoil hat I'm ready for
the information no no no he put the
tinfoil hat on
oh yeah just yeah pretty is about to
engage in a battle and then the the
generals come in with their mind-control
device and they're like cranking the
wheel but alex jones like you know just
happen this just makes me think i can't
wait i am seriously looking forward to
the debate a day later the debate
between Trump and Biden man oh but wait
wait hold on if I can't wait all right
what day after that article comes out
hold on I got I got to show you a little
bit more right they see the comments
which Biden made in an interview with
Trevor no on The Daily Show are not the
first time that the former president and
presumptive nominee while he's the
nominee has suggested that he believes
the incumbent may well seek to fiddle
with the results quote mark my words
mark my words fat I think he's going to
try to kick back the election somehow
come up with some rationale
why I can't be held Biden said in April
but the real danger here blah blah blah
okay but here's a day later this is what
we get
Trump says he will do other things if he
loses the election it's so boring
yeah he doesn't even have a specific
noun to represent what he would do
he's like dude are you kidding me I have
all these businesses that I've been off
not working on like I'm gonna go build
buildings and places like what and put
my name on him that's let's dip our toes
into real life yeah please US President
Donald Trump said he will go on to do
other things if he loses the November
3rd election after a Democratic opponent
Joe Biden said the Republican might
cheat and refuse to leave the White
House quote man certainly if I don't win
I don't win I mean you know go on and do
other things Trump told Fox News I'm
just looking at that ballot you guys
can't see this but there's a ballot that
can't do I have we've talked about the
Varde yeah so there's there's some some
stuff going on and I can see that bout
from here that's not for anyone that
lives here but none of us got our
ballots and none of us got ballots so
that's an issue and it's weird that
they're painting this picture like Trump
is gonna cheat Trump is the one who's
gonna cheat I'm just like why are you
saying that so much but the reality is
Trump's response is very boring exactly
everything about Trump has been so much
more boring than they've tried to claim
and then what's up with this I keep
seeing this good pop pop up that yeah
okay so the presumptive Democratic
convention yet come is he not or is it
Hillary yes they just make up your mind
they can't say it why not
what does in the middle of August or
something with the DNC and officially
declares he's the only one because
they're gonna say Hillary because yeah
you know I think it's B Cuomo maybe no
way I have to wonder man are they are
they really helping Trump win like I
don't believe it I'm like I think about
what what people and moderates are
saying right now they feel like Trump
can't win they're scared they're losing
their country and then all sudden Trump
pulls an upset and everyone feels
inspired like I'll tell you what man
I've been thinking this since Trump won
in the first place where it's like that
actually it's not even on me there's a
conspiracy theory that Trump is part of
the deep state and cuz it conspiracy
they remind you I'm not saying it's true
the idea is that you look at these
photos of Trump and Hillary together
mm-hmm you look at these photos of like
Trump and an Epstein together and so
there's a conspiracy theory that Trump
is a global billionaire elite but he was
propped up as an outsider still part of
their elite circle so that he can get
all of the anti-government
anti-establishment types normally would
be opposed not cheering for him hold on
hold on Alex Jones is the funniest thing
I remember Alex Jones like very
anti-government all of a sudden now he's
very Pro Trump right so so what do you
end up with you end up with a lot of
these people who are anti-government
okay now actively supporting the federal
government because Trump is in there is
forcing people to engage that's the
conspiracy theory okay they have used
Trump to increase civic engagement
people were disenfranchised had no
confidence and govern weren't voting all
of a sudden now they're voting all of a
sudden everybody's involved sports teams
are gone everybody's in politics now
it's true if people stopped caring about
the government had stopped paying
attention they would lose confidence in
it and it would just fall apart so there
are some people believe what we're
seeing right now is meant to make it
seem like Trump is the outsider underdog
and he wins and it restores people's
faith and the ability to save their
country but you don't think so
well no no I there is things about what
you just said that I agree with and
things that that make me smirk and and
giggle a little bit the the fact that
they would think that he's part of the
deep State because I mean I've I if you
haven't noticed I've been doing a lot of
research and I'm furthering myself I I
know a lot more than I did a few months
ago and one of those things that I've
been researching is Trump I want to know
about the president and I I I'm like
finding out all these things about him
that that do not fit that narrative like
the that whole deep state thing it's
just why not I mean he I mean he prodded
Jesse Jackson's run for president in the
90s do you know that like I didn't know
that that's what new information how
does that mean he's not deep state well
I mean he's he's a civil rights activist
like he's he cares about the the people
that are that do work but there are
there are a lot of Democrats that are
pro-establishment that are civil rights
activists
yeah I don't know I I guess I guess the
argument of him being the deep state
it's like you cannot it you can say
anyone is they can say that I am like
anyone could be it could be a conspiracy
but like I have yes like any sort of
proof of that sort all I see is him
being a humanitarian actually like the
things that he's done it we'll know
before he even ran for office he reminds
me of the South Park episode on the 9/11
truth movement okay where the government
the real conspiracy was that the
government was trying to convince
everyone there's a conspiracy so that
people think they're in control of
everything
and then at the end Kyle and Stan like
realize and George George double she's
there and they're like wait a minute
you're lying there is no conspiracy you
made the conspiracy up and then there's
like he gives an explanation where he's
like we need people to think that we are
all powerful otherwise they actually
will threaten us I mean come on what if
we told people that we actually lost
control and a group of people in the
cave we're able to attack us and get
away with it yeah we can't have that so
we need people to think you know it's
like it's a it's a funny funny thought
well I always thought that American
doesn't negotiate with terrorists is
that that's true right
you've made it clear already sure and
you you've explained why well the
kidnappers at least in like you know
four countries I know but the the the
statement Rob the statement goes America
does not negotiate with terrorists
period and I'm fairly certain
every single person in America has just
watched these people just terrorized and
ripped statues down oh man take Oliver
and they fell on bent knee yes and said
it's my range no not everybody you know
not certainly not me not you yeah you
know I'm it's it's dolena Democrats it's
a democratic side of things but I'm not
confident I'm not because the propaganda
is is is so thick I agree and it's hard
to break through I'm unit man on
Facebook especially it's on Facebook
right people that I don't I don't
associate with anymore I've cut them out
of my life it's insane
somebody's of this they've said to me
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you